and days after their daughter's sudden
death the parents of a local college
student are now sharing her story police
say that Katarina Johnson who was a
freshman at UNLV was killed in a DUI
related crash Monday Sasha Loftus joins
us from the campus tonight with more on
her family's message in Astoria you'll
only see on eight news now
Katarina had just started school here at
UNLV a month ago now her family is
coming to terms with her sudden death as
they plead with others to think twice
before driving impaired she was just a
great person she touched so many Souls
described as a truly special Soul
Katarina Johnson's life was cut short
before it could truly begin she had so
many plans so many things she wanted to
do days after she was killed in a
suspected DUI crash her parents gregan
Alexandra remember the immeasurable
impact she made at just 18 years old she
was just
so special in who she was how she
dressed how she talked
Arena was driving to a friend's house
here on the us-95 near Boulder City
early Monday morning when police say
this woman Taylor Madison swerved into
her Lane and hit her head on it was
terrific
it was way worse than we could even
imagine now as those who loved her most
face unimaginable grief they want to
show others what can happen if you drive
impaired it's not worth it to try to
chance it not because you might hurt
yourself because you might hurt someone
else while they do their best to carry
cat's memory with them now no one should
have to bury their child especially when
they haven't even started their life and
every minute from this day forward it's
an honor that I was your dad cat's
parents tell me she was studying
computer science and wanted to get into
coding they do have a GoFundMe up now to
help with funeral expenses if you'd like
to donate reporting from UNLV Sasha
Loftus 8 News Now